okay or bad guys are back in class we  did like the sunken swamp or some [ __ ]  like that I don't forget  [Music]  [Music]  it's a scandal with you there are  unsettling rumblings in the mountains of  the overworld whispered rumors say the  images are building something dreadful  far beneath these ancient mines  something of sucked  metal and flame only a hero such as  yourself could brave the cavernous  underground and uncover the truth  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  so the rumors were true  the images are building a grateful Forge  under the mountain  [Music]